thank you don't make this is yet another
example of Microsoft researchers
commitment to work very closely with
para groups to improve our products next
I'm going to invite a lead researcher
Quintin to come to tell us about Sora
the cutting edge next generation a
software-defined radio powerful ok thank
you for metoya instruction and welcome
everyone on so today they want is
complication is camo very prevalent so
actually became the essential part of a
daily life so look at your foe actually
there already lambros our radios
technology have been integrated there
for example we have Bluetooth Wi-Fi jsf
Oh voice voice call and the 3g for the
data service and there are also many
other water technology that is designed
to integrate to help you big critter
connectivity and better experience
however traditionally age different
radio technology is implemented with the
specialized hug so integrated old this
kind of heated units were hardware into
a single platform it's very difficult
and caustic so then comes an idea of
software review the idea is to replace
all this specialized hardware which is a
common a general-purpose computing
platform then you can implement all this
video functionality with software so the
software video actually translate the
communication problem from a hardware
problem to a software problem so the
obvious is the benefit is obvious
because the software brings you the
great flexibility and the
programmability so you can write a bad
wireless protocols that understand and
adapt to the environment and deliver
better performance further
the cast also can be saved because all
this video functionality I rely on the
same common and computing platform it
also a great research platform that you
can quickly do the prototyping and get a
result also easier to develop and the
reducer cycle from research to the
market but the real challenge here is
that if the software can present this
high-speed introducing glow at a certain
speed as a special highway so this
motivates the project's aura let's carry
the in Microsoft Research issue so the
goal of this solar project is to build a
purpose of the video based on existing
community PC platform actually we
developed two key technology to enable
this one thing is that we take advantage
of the country pc pc bus that we use
native pcie-based a PCIe interface to
build an interface that can transfer the
Dementors wireless signals from the
video from n to the pc memory as a matta
gig a pitiful second circuit a second is
a bunch of software innovations that
make full use of the modern multi-core
CPUs that's using the parallel computing
to speed up your digital signal
processing also to support real hard
process the real harm programming so
with all this technology actually we can
implement the arc on the latest while is
like a 0 to D level but also can
supposed the future while standard not
ltd after this result the Soraa had been
well recognized our world wallet we were
popular the paper the guys the best
paper word and win a number of the
better demo word in his top conference
and
this January the communication of ACN
has highlighted the result of Sarah and
such that it is one of the most
significant the wise paper is recently
so we have make this aura technology are
open for the academic research MSR has
sponsored the academic program that we
collaborate with 18 universities
worldwide to do the widest research base
of a solar technology we also shape this
the strip that as an immense honest of
the reader extender kit that you can you
can get it from our downloaded from our
website and now he's already have 170
users and actively use the auto
technology do the research so with all
these efforts are just on emphasize that
we are trying to want to closely
collaborative org academic partners to
empower the academic wise research with
this cutting-edge technology so let's
conclude my talk and send you for your
attention